the presidential elections are drawing
near and on the streets of Rio De
Janeiro there's no shortage of political
opinions
I would like to see more schools more
hospitals and for the candidate who wins
to invest in the future of our children
though most here agree this election
will be a defining moment for the future
direction of the country there's a lack
of optimism that whoever wins the
presidency will improve the lives of
Brazil's poorest citizens
I don't think anyone will fix the
situation in Brazil some receive more
While others receive less there is no
Health Care no education and there is
nothing left for the poor
on Sunday Brazilians will head to the
polls for a first round of voting though
officially there are almost a dozen
candidates running for president the
election is a race between incumbent
president jahid bolsonaro and former
president luisi nacio Lula da Silva who
has been leading in the polls
political analysts here in Brazil say
the country is starkly divided along
ideological lines even now on the eve of
the elections the race between Lula and
bolsonaro is too close to predict
Economist Mauro rochley says that while
both Lula and bolsonaro have been vague
in their campaign promises they still
polarize the electorate
what is steering this polarization is a
rhetoric from both sides that the other
is a radical with Lula saying that
bolsonaro represents the radical right
and bolsonaro saying that Lula
represents the threat of communism
Brazilian electoral law dictates that
presidential candidates need at least 50
percent plus one vote to win
if neither Lula or bolsonaro achieve
that during Sunday's vote a second round
of voting will take place on October
30th
Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera Rio de Janeiro